paris the proud beautiful see differently
a place of longing for centuries
a city with many nicknames paris the
city of arts the city of fashion the
city of gourmets and probably the
most beautiful nickname paris the city of
love none of this wants to match the
pictures that have been taken since the attacks
shape the city that stands after the attack in
january paris stands the city
mourns again for its victims its
carelessness for its sense of freedom
but the people want to preserve their
special way of life
we ​​have to go on and
believe in peace
the only way to fight is like this  to
live as before so krohn
i still believe in fraternity
freedom equality fraternity the
slogan of the french revolution on
the basis of these values
cultural life in
paris was also able to develop a unique
blend of art fashion design and
architecture
many filmmakers have moved away from the myth
get inspired by paris  d
strengthened him like woody allen in his
midnight in paris a homage to paris
as a meeting place for artists, writers
and intellectual
painters like pablo picasso vincent van gogh
or edgar degas
they were inspired by the still new,
unfamiliar freedom of that day the
freedom to dare something new  also causes
revolutions in the fashion world coco chanel
freed women from corsets dior
created the new look
and yves sarault invented the pants suit
for women fashionable experiments
that ensured that paris got its reputation as the
fashion capital not only of europe but of
the world and keeps it to this day
the typical parisian style is actually
an anti-fashion style perhaps because in
this capital passion and fashion is so
omnipresent perhaps best
but the savoir vivre this
zest for life can be played out in the culinary scene
of paris in one of the many
street cafes where everyone  guest
who can meet in paris or in a
the traditional brasseries such as
la coupole the attacks on paris
will remain anchored in the city's memory
but
the parisians don't want their freedom to be
taken away
b
more
like that